President Trump is back in the White
House after last night's rally in the
battleground state of Michigan he waited
for the house vote then made the second
longest speech of his presidency Ben
Tracy is at the White House for us so
Ben good morning how was the president
responding good morning so that was
quite a barnburner of a speech last
night and it's clear President Trump did
not want to be impeached but now that he
is his campaign is planning to use it to
raise a lot of money and keep the base
fired up
it is hoping to make history by getting
an impeached president re-elected in a
split screen for the ages president
Trump was cheered by an adoring crowd
while he was condemned by the House of
Representatives oh I think we have a
vote coming in that now impeached
president given the vote totals while on
stage so we got every single Republican
voted for us whoa crazy Nancy Pelosi's
House Democrats
have branded themselves with an eternal
mark of shame in it it really is it's a
disgrace
this event was dubbed a merry christmas'
rally but it was far from a silent night
loud chants of four more years president
defiantly mocked the charges against him
this is the first impeachment where
there's no crime I say tell me what I
did please well we don't know you
violated the Constitution White House
aides and since the president was
working during most of Wednesday's
impeachment debate but his Twitter
account said otherwise as mr. Trump
responded in real-time to what he called
atrocious lies by the radical left this
lawless partisan impeachment is a
political suicide March for the Democrat
Party have you seen my polls in the last
four weeks well the president is
publicly shrugging off impeachment
sources here at the White House say that
he cares a lot about what impeachment
means for his legacy and that in
particular he hates the idea that his
name will forever be used in the same
sentence as Bill Clinton's Gale all
right thank you very much Ben